okay let's give this a shot
now i wonder what kind of strategies
you're using
um i wonder what kinds of things you're
trying to do like if you're up against
the brick wall
what other kinds of things can you try
what i'm going to do
is i'm going to try and first i'm going
to have to put some labels on here so i
can talk about it
you might notice i haven't gone for this
actual set of numbers i'm just going to
go straight for the throat and go for
the general case
it's not as hard as it looks okay and
then we'll apply it to this and see how
we go okay
now i'm going to label it and then we'll
start talking about what defines this
ellipse okay
so you can see i've got my um i've got
my lips there it's just the
general one i've got my one of my
directricies here
and one of my guy there okay now i need
a few more points here to start talking
about this
i need these two points you're going to
see why in a second so being that
they're on the major axis at the moment
don't want to call lower cases that's a
length so i'm going to go for
a1 and a2 okay you might want to try and
follow along if you can because it's
going to
start getting involved if you're not
keeping up with my steps
now i'm going to place a point on the
directrix i i'm just going to call it n
i don't know why just it's a nice letter
so they go
right now you might notice i've chosen
all of these points here all along the x
axis now the reason why
is because calculating things along this
straight line is super super easy
okay for instance suppose i wanted to
work
out which ratio i'm interested in let's
have a look at this one
from the focus to that point there
a one okay the closest point
and then from that closest point to the
equivalent point in the directrix
okay so i've got two distances there i
guess they'd be called
s a1 and
a1 n or a1 okay
what's the ratio between think about it
you don't know anything about this there
are numbers on here all you've got is
the definitions what's the ratio between
these
now the whole definition of these conic
sections in this ellipse right
is that this distance here that ratio
that's the eccentricity whatever it is
okay so for me what i've chosen is
you're gonna have this being this
interesting times that
okay you can almost kind of see it
actually i mean it's almost the half
that we chose from the previous example
it doesn't have to be
but there you go okay now
in exactly the same way suppose i'm
thinking about this point now
okay so let me put this on in a slightly
different color
so what if i were comparing sorry this
distance
to the focus okay and then that one
all the way over
to the directrix okay so this time
what i'm comparing is s to a2
and then all the way from n to a2
okay so i've got sorry
these are the two lengths i'm comparing
what's the ratio
it's still e isn't it this is still the
distance i'm still comparing
the distance from some points in focus
and some point to the directrix that's
what the definition is
okay so it's still bad okay now believe
it or not
those two equations are almost all you
need okay to do what we're going to do
here
right so i'm going to call this actually
did i name them yeah even name them
let's call this one and two okay
seems simple if you were going around in
circles you've done all this crazy stuff
you're like
where am i going where am i making
progress this is it
that's all i'm gonna use yeah get ready
watch okay
what would happen if we subtractively
should we subtract them
let's subtract actually which one we're
going to do two minus one so what it
doesn't matter yeah
two is further i suppose i shouldn't do
that one
two minus one okay so bottom minus the
top
what happens so i've got
s a two minus s a one on the left hand
side
and then i've got a factor of there's a
factor in e you can see that in this
column so
i'm going to take that out a two m minus
a one
m okay now you need to look really
really closely at this
okay sa2
minus sa1 what is that distance
okay now by the way don't forget i know
some things about this i know some
things about the same major axis and the
semi-minor axis and how long they are
right not to worry about the semi-minor
axis at the moment because that's up and
down
yeah but you know that this distance
here is
it's just a okay good all right
now therefore what's this guy equal to
can you see it i'll give you a clue it's
almost impossible
to work out what it is without actually
having drawn these lengths
on your diagram okay does anyone i'm not
going to ask you
does anyone think they know what it's
actually equal to
hands just one maybe how confident are
you
sure oh no not that confident you gotta
guess okay
i'm gonna give you a second maybe like
okay maybe more than a second maybe half
a minute okay you think do you think you
know
yeah yeah okay all right i want you to
want to try and confirm the rest of you
drawing a diagram this is my clue the
fact that i've draw all of these lines
here
i'm trying to compare them to one
another and get them in relation to this
because that's the only thing that i
really know tells me the length of these
things
okay what distance is
that what is that
what does it leave you with give you 30
seconds to even come up with something
don't just get it by the way see if you
can be convinced of it and explain it to
the person next to you all right
now if you think if you reckon you've
got an answer i want you to write it
down just so that
in 10 seconds when you're right or wrong
your friend next you can be like see
i because otherwise
you know people will magically change
what they're saying you're like yes see
i totally
said well mr lucifer all right you're
right what's it equal to
now watch carefully i said there's a lot
of symmetry here
yeah so i'm going to take advantage of
the fact that it's symmetrical
across the y-axis okay so for instance
this distance over here um sa1
a1s okay if i were to map it across the
other side
where would it be and don't forget there
are two foci right so i can actually put
in the other one
over here suppose you could call it s1
and s2 if you like okay
now that distance there sa1 right there
is here okay
so if you like what i'm doing is sa2
there minus sa1 there
here i am okay this distance here
is s a two minus s a one
you see it that's whatever right good
okay
now you think that's not a huge
improvement
oh yeah it is don't forget what we're
trying to work out okay
um we were saying look you've got an
equation sorry starting
you started with eccentricity focus
and directrix you landed on an equation
can we go the other way
right so we're trying to find out some
information about the directrix
or the focus or the eccentricity okay
and the reason why this is a big leap
forward is
that distance there symmetry
right can we say it any simpler than
there
symmetry what's half the distance
it's just it's it's out of here here
we're here here right from the origin to
either one
it doesn't matter which focus okay so
this is actually equal to double the
distance from
the origin to the focus okay now just
just suppose
just suppose this distance okay
was i don't know three okay
if this is three what are the
coordinates of the focus
the focus is just sitting on the axis
right you know this distance in this
case it'll be
three zero okay you've already got the
focus you know everything about it from
what you've got here
now of course i don't actually know if
it's three but
i almost have enough information if i
come back to here okay so what have we
just established that sa2 minus sa1
is double the distance from the origin
to the focus that's really important
okay let's have a look at the right hand
side which i think actually might be
easier
okay a2n
that longest distance there okay minus
a1 m this distance just just from the
edge of the ellipse
to the directrix okay if you're
subtracting
this little bit from the whole this
one's easier what's it equal to what do
you get left with
you just get left with the major axis
don't you okay so what you've got here
is
e times 2 a little a
yeah okay great two on both sides so
os is equal to put it in alphabetical
order
a e so the coordinate to the focus is
not
three necessarily but i do know that
it's
the semi major axis
times the eccentricity and because i
consider the case where the center is
the origin
i'm just right level there so it's a e
comma zero
so you can say os equals ae implying
the focus is ae
0 okay